if the real major has taught us anything
it's to expect the unexpected whatever
you'd like to say say it now
there have been countless upsets so far
a Caster was ejected from the tournament
after causing a fight and FaZe the
number one team in the world went Owen
three and is now knocked out of the
tournament we haven't even gotten to the
playoffs yet listen I knew this was
going to be crazy but holy [__]
[Music]
to say that the real major has been hype
would be a big understatement and a lot
of the praise needs to go to the amazing
fans in attendance they haven't even
gotten to the stadium yet and these
[__] have already busted out
instruments ridiculous signs and amazing
chance
he's here on the spirit side you saw
that one quick maybe trying to use this
atmosphere right you know in-game
leaders in the past have used loud
environments like this now although they
are going above and beyond I think that
level of passion was somewhat expected
from the Brazilian home crowd what was
hard to imagine is just how
unpredictable these matches would be and
just how cursed our pickups would turn
out for those that don't know every
major allows players to buy a pass and
that PASS gives you a bronze coin that's
dedicated to that tournament you can
then participate in what's called
pickums where you choose what teams you
think will move on in each round get
enough correct in every bracket and your
coin gets upgraded to silver gold and
then Diamond some tournaments are easier
than others to get the diamond coined
and people assume that the real major
was going to be one of the more
difficult ones just not this difficult
off the rip in Challenger stage
Greyhound gaming the team that everybody
picked to go on three ended up getting a
win against Cloud9 of all teams he is
stuck in the open stranded and desperate
and Greyhound just one bullet Landing
away
to add to that those who wanted to
Believe In The Crowd buff ended up
getting burnt when Imperial and oo
nation became the ones getting knocked
out without a win on top of that
favorites Vitality in C9 ended up just
squeaking through at the bottom of the
bracket with mouse and bad news Eagles
being the ones to go undefeated as crazy
as all that seems things got even
weirder both inside and outside the
server you had entire teams crashing
mid-round and fans getting accused of
trying to give hints to certain players
basically whatever expectations you had
going into this major they were probably
wrong but strangest of all news broke
that CS go Caster sadakiss was removed
and replaced from the major after
causing a disturbance at the hotel that
required Police Services it was reported
that he returned from a bar intoxicated
and then got into an altercation with
gala's infuria while they were trying to
film content allegedly sadakiss threw
something out the group and even broke a
TV Police Services were called and
eventually ESL removed him from the
Talon pool as of now there hasn't been
any information on what exactly sparked
this altercation or what happened during
it luckily the legend stage was about to
kick off and take us away from all the
drama plus we'd get to finally see some
of the tournament favorites in action
unfortunately that would not last too
long because the number one ranked team
in the world FaZe would end up getting
blasted by every team they faced
becoming the first ones eliminated from
the stage
let me try to emphasize just how crazy
this is FaZe was the favorite for the
tournament and this loss not only sent
them home but eliminated their chance at
getting the Grand Slam on top of this
being utterly insane it also sparked a
conversation about how something like
this could happen although Kerrigan
tried to take the blame for his team's
shortcomings many people pointed to the
tournament's format as the real culprit
you see faze's first game was against C9
who are ranked fifth globally and their
second was against Vitality who are
ranked second this is objectively a more
difficult route than one that let's say
Furia had but honestly that's just the
way the cookie crumbles sometimes FaZe
was the number one seeded team and after
C9 and vitality fumbled the bag in the
Challenger stage they were put into the
lower seeds so with the way the format
works and how the other game shaked out
FaZe had to face the 7th and 8th seeded
teams in the legend stage who just so
happened to be pretty damn good teams
now there are other formats you can use
like double e limb or round robin that
might help avoid the toxic matchups but
it's not great for the players or the
viewing experience another argument
against the current format is that it
can lead to Super uneven matchups later
on in the tournament as a team that
maybe shouldn't have made it ends up
facing a really good team and just gets
stomped but at the same time this is how
you can truly get some of the craziest
outcomes sure a lot of people are salty
they don't get to see their phase Navi
storyline come true but if you limit
yourself to that view you rob yourself
of something potentially more amazing
honestly take it all in vitality and
liquid were also sent packing and Navi
had to go the full 5 series just to move
on and with the playoffs just around the
corner we've got some crazy matchups
Furia has been playing amazing and they
have the support of an entire nation
behind them but Navi is going to be a
very tough series to start with that
being said if anyone can pull it off I
think it's them now as much as I would
love to see that happen I can't help but
feel that this might be c9's tournament
although they had a shaky start they've
been looking very strong and their path
to Grand finals is very doable now I
will say you should take all of my
predictions with with a grain of salt
I'm not very smart and my pickums are
down dastardly right now honestly this
might be the hardest Diamond coin to
achieve in the history of Cs go but
whatever happens I honestly don't think
I care anymore this has been one of the
most unpredictable csgo Majors I've ever
seen in a good way and yes I am a
die-hard Brazilian CS fan so I'm biased
when I say this but I think it has the
potential to be one of the greatest
tournaments in Esports history
what if there's a tournament that
somehow all of Southern Ontario was
invested in and everyone just fought
like the whole world stage finally
discovered what the southern Ontario
accent was there's a whole bunch of
people saying oh [__] bod let's [__]
go bad dangle Snipes Sally safe sorry
that would be great though or maybe
humiliating I don't know Dougie what are
you doing what are you doing there get
us a goddamn CS go tournament